Tras décadas y décadas, cientos de años
dormido, el gigante chino por fin se ha despertado.
(Durante las últimas cuatro décadas el crecimiento
económico alcanzó un ritmo medio del entorno
al 10% anual. A lo largo de todos estos años
China se transformó, pasó de ser una sociedad
rural de agricultores pobres a una país industrial
moderno con grandes metrópolis.
El PIB per cápita ajustado por la inflación
se multiplicó por 24, la esperanza media
de vida aumentó en más de 10 años y más
de 700 millones de personas dejaron atrás
la pobreza según datos del Banco Mundial.)
Y de hecho, en 2020, el propio Banco Mundial
publicó nuevas estimaciones que colocaban
ya a la economía china por delante de la
norteamericana cuándo el PIB se ajusta por
la diferencia de precios. Y no se trata sólo
del Banco Mundial, las estimaciones del FMI
apuntan exactamente en la misma dirección.
Incluso, el coronavirus, no se, pareció todo
un ejemplo de éxito y superioridad del modelo
chino. Mientras que el gobierno de Xi Jinping
logró contener rápidamente la pandemia y
cerrar el 2020 con buenos datos económicos,
la realidad no solo en Estados Unidos sino
en todo occidente fue muy diferente.
Pues bien, el caso es que todos estos cambios
han hecho, según las encuestas realizadas,
que una gran mayoría de personas consideren
que China superará próximamente a los mismísimos
Estados Unidos como la primera superpotencia
mundial.
Lo cual no resulta especialmente sorprendente.
Pensadlo un momento, en el imaginario colectivo
los chinos lo hacen todo, lo fabrican todo.
Prácticamente se están convirtiendo en los
dueños de medio mundo.
Y, ¿qué queréis que os diga? Aparentemente,
los datos parecen claros: China tiene un PIB
ajustado mayor, mayores niveles de inversión,
mayores flujos comerciales y su crecimiento
económico es más alto.
[Ya se pueden preparar los yankis.]
Por ser, los chinos son, incluso, los segundos
mayores propietarios de deuda norteamericana
tras Japón.
Ahora bien, un momento. Echad el freno.
¿Quiere decir todo esto que estamos condenados
a la hegemonía china? ¿Qué, con toda seguridad,
el país de los tres reinos se convertirá
en la gran superpotencia del mundo? ¿Qué
los Estados Unidos están acabados como primera
superpotencia económica y militar?
Pues, mucho ojo, porque con China las cosas
no son siempre lo que parecen.
Queridos amigos, amigas de Visualpolitik:
¿Qué dicen exactamente los datos?
Atentos.
[Por cierto, ¿Habéis invertido en bolsa
alguna vez? ¿Está la bolsa cara o barata?
¿Por qué la bolsa norteamericana no deja
de batir una y otra vez sus máximos históricos?
¿Estamos ante la madre de todas las burbujas?
No os perdais el último vídeo de “Si lo
Hubiera Sabido”, el nuevo canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejo el link en la descripción.
Sigamos.]
(LA ECONOMÍA DEL DRAGÓN)
Lo primero qué podríamos decir es que hay
que coger con pinzas los datos chinos porque
podrían no ser del todo fiables. Es algo
de lo que ya os hemos hablado en VisualPolitik.
Pero, podéis creerme, sean más o menos exactos
es el menor de los problemas a la hora de
valorar la tesis de que China superará pronto
a los Estados Unidos.
Al fin y al cabo, es innegable que durante
los últimos 40 años el país ha experimentado
un crecimiento y un desarrollo gigantesco.
Respecto a esto no hay ninguna duda.
Basta con ver echar un vistazo a sus enormes
rascacielos, sus modernas infraestructuras,
a la pujante clase media o las nuevas empresas
chinas que como Alibaba o Tencent están extendiendo
sus tentáculos por todo el mundo.
Ahora bien, esta no es ni mucho menos toda
la historia.
Lo cierto es que los Estados Unidos siguen
siendo mucho, muchísimo más ricos que China.
Y lo que es más importante, la diferencia
lejos de reducirse se está ampliando cada
vez más y más..
Espera, espera, stop. Un momento: ¿estás
de broma? ¿Qué cada vez hay más diferencias
entre Estados Unidos y China? ¿Pero no habíamos
dicho que el PIB ajustado chino ya ha superado
al de los Estados Unidos?
Pues sí, pero el problema, amigos, es que
el PIB es un indicador bruto que no mide bien
los costes ni la generación de riqueza ni
tampoco el margen que un país tiene para
convertirse en una superpotencia.
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Pues.. Fijaos.
(Desde el año 2000, el porcentaje de millonarios
respecto al conjunto de la población se ha
incrementado en China en apenas medio punto,
mientras que en los Estados Unidos el incremento
ha sido 10 veces superior. Hoy por hoy, casi
el 9% de los adultos estadounidenses tienen
un patrimonio neto superior al millón de
dólares
De hecho, según datos de Credit Suisse la
diferencia de riqueza entre los norteamericanos
y los chinos se ha ampliado desde el año
2011 en más de 12 billones de dólares.)
Pero, ¿Cómo es esto posible? ¿No es acaso
China la fábrica del mundo? Pues sí, el
problema amigos es que es una fábrica muy
ineficiente. China produce mucho, de ahí
que su PIB sea tan alto, pero también lo
hace con unos costes de producción enormes.
Es decir, la economía china es grande pero
terriblemente ineficiente.
Y no, no me refiero a los salarios, sino al
consumo de inputs como, por ejemplo, la energía,
el agua, las materias primas o incluso el
número de trabajadores necesarios para desempeñar
una tarea.
Además, luego, una parte muy importante de
la producción de China se consume en satisfacer
las necesidades de sus 1.400 millones de habitantes
y también del propio gobierno chino.
Y el problema es que el PIB mide la producción
anual digamos en términos brutos, pero no
mide bien los costes ni el excedente que finalmente
se convierte en riqueza.
Y ahí, ahí es dónde está precisamente
la trampa. Y también es lo que explica que,
por ejemplo, un país tan pobre como la India
tenga el 5º mayor PIB del mundo a pesar de
que apenas tiene recursos para actuar como
una superpotencia y la inmensa mayor parte
de su población es muy pobre.
[Conclusión: cuidado con los datos que utilizas]
Pero no nos desviemos. Ya se lo que os estáis
preguntado: ¿Cómo de ineficiente es la economía
china y por qué demonios lo es tanto? Pues..
Veréis, el crecimiento económico de China
puede explicarse casi por completo por el
crecimiento de los recursos productivos.
Me explico. Entre el 90 y el 97% del crecimiento
económico chino ha estado vinculado a la
incorporación de más trabajadores y la inversión
en capital física. En cambio, lo que se denomina
como “productividad total de los factores”
apenas ha representado entre el 3 y el 7%
de la expansión
Y os preguntaréis, ¿por qué es esto tan
importante? Pues porque esta productividad
es lo que permite hacer más con menos. Fijaos.
(Imaginaos que tenemos 2 fábricas con la
misma producción, pero en cambio la primera
tiene una máquina y un trabajador, mientras
que la segunda tiene 2 trabajadores y dos
máquinas.
Evidentemente la primera fábrica es mucho
más eficiente, más productiva, logra hacer
más con menos, de tal forma que por un lado
requiere invertir menos capital y por tanto
acumular menos deuda y por otro deja libres
factores productivos - una máquina y un trabajador
- para poder montar otros negocios.)
¿Veis la diferencia? Pues eso es exactamente
lo que ocurre con el caso de China. Como la
productividad es muy baja, para mantener el
crecimiento económico el gobierno ha tenido
que invertir enormes cantidades de dinero,
lo que ha multiplicado la deuda.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre 2007 y
2017, la deuda no financiera de China se ha
multiplicado por 4, lo que supone un incremento
mayor que el de cualquier otro país. Y de
hecho ya ha superado la media de las economías
avanzadas.
Es algo que explica titulares como este:
(Evergrande y el fin del modelo chino de "construir,
construir y construir". Valorado en 41.000
millones de dólares en 2020, el espectacular
desmoronamiento del grupo inmobiliario expone
profundas grietas en la estrategia de crecimiento
de Pekín. FT)
Y no nos engañemos. Como esta tendencia no
se puede mantener permanentemente y además
la sobreinversión ha generado un montón
de excedentes de producción por todas partes:
fábricas que no se necesita, ciudades fantasma
o costes crecientes a lo largo de toda la
economía - pensad por ejemplo, en los interés,
el mayor gasto energético, los mayores salarios
por la menor disponibilidad de trabajadores,
etcétera, etcétera - ; el crecimiento chino
se ha venido ralentizando durante los últimos
años.
Y la cuestión es que a diferencia de China,
Estados Unidos tiene una economía mucho más
eficiente y sus empresas se posicionan entre
las más competitivas del mundo. El resultado
es que su productividad por trabajador no
solo es mucho más alta que en China sino
que, además, la diferencia es cada vez mayor.
Además, con una cuarta parte de población
sus costes de bienestar y seguridad interna
son muy inferiores. Por ejemplo, con una producción
menor tienen que alimentar, vestir y calentar
a mucha más gente, lo que hace que el excedente
de producción, esto la acumulación de riqueza
sea muuucho más reducida.
El resultado: China crece más pero Estados
Unidos se hace cada vez más y más rico.
Y evidentemente cuánto más rico seas más
capacidades tendrás para mantener el status
de superpotencia.
¿A que ahora ya las cosas os parecen un poquito
diferentes? Pues esperad un momento, porque
no hemos hecho más que empezar.
Según cálculos del Banco Mundial y de Naciones
Unidas, el capital humano - esto es la formación,
las habilidades, la experiencia - supone más
de la mitad de la riqueza de la mayoría de
países y hasta el 80% de la riqueza de las
naciones más desarrolladas.
Y esto es justo uno de los grandes fuertes
de los Estados Unidos.
(En China poco más del 10% de la mano de
obra tiene un título universitario frente
al 44% de la mano de obra estadounidense.
Además la calidad de las universidades norteamericanas
está muy por delante, lo que es normal, porque
en China ni siquiera existe un acceso libre
a internet o a las investigaciones científicas
del resto del mundo.
Así, mientras que en la clasificación del
“Center for World University Rankings”
la mejor universidad china aparece en el puesto
58, los Estados Unidos tienen 29 de las 50
mejores universidades del mundo. Y no, el
resto de rankings no son muy diferentes.
Para colmo cada año China pierde cientos
de miles de trabajadores bien formados que
se marchan a trabajar al extranjero, entre
ellos decenas de miles de ingenieros, científicos,
inventores y emprendedores.
Estados Unidos en cambio recibe un millón
de trabajadores extranjeros cada año. Entre
ellos miles de científicos e ingenieros procedentes
de todo el mundo, incluyendo de la propia
China.)
En otras palabras. Estados Unidos tiene mejor
plantilla, mejor cantera y encima cada año
que pasa aprovecha mejor el mercado de fichajes.
En parte esto es lo que explica los mayores
niveles de productividad. Estados Unidos se
ha especializado en gran medida en productos
de alto valor añadido y tecnológicamente
avanzados que son muy difíciles de replicar
para China.
(De hecho, una cosa que no se cuenta es que
de cada dólar de producción china exportada
a Estados Unidos, 55 centavos corresponden
a componentes y servicios producidos en los
propios Estados Unidos.)
Luego, la creciente intromisión de Xi Jinping
en las empresas privadas - ahí está sin
ir más lejos la guerra desatada contra las
grandes corporaciones tecnológicas privadas
del país - tampoco ayuda a que la productividad
se incremente en el futuro. Lo mismo que ocurre
con la corrupción o las trabas que impone
el Partido Comunista a todos aquellos emprendedores
que no sean de la cuerda.
Y un último problema: la demografía. China
está envejeciendo mucho más rápido que
Estados Unidos y su población mayor de 65
años se triplicará con creces de aquí a
mediados de siglo. Tal y como podéis ver
la evolución de los dos países es muy pero
que muy diferente:
China tiene un problema enorme con las pensiones,
su población se va a contraer fuertemente
durante las próximas décadas y la mayor
proporción de personas con más de 65 años
supone que el país tendrá que detraer recursos
de su producción para poder atenderles.
Así que, amigos, amigas, no, por mucho que
no le guste a Xi Jinping, no parece que el
poder económico de China vaya a superar en
las próximas décadas al de Estados Unidos
ni tampoco que el país asiático vaya a tener
los recursos suficientes como para luchar
por el primer puesto de superpotencia mundial.
[Son simple y llanamente los datos. Y no,
no se pueden cambiar.]
Pero ojo porque no se trata sólo de la economía.
Algo muy parecido ocurre también con las
fuerzas armadas.
Atentos.
(LA ESPADA DEL DRAGÓN)
En un pasado vídeo os contamos cómo la estrategia
de China en lo respectivo a su ejército pasa
esencialmente por convertirse en una gran
potencia regional.
Porque de momento las diferencias a nivel
global son abismales.
Por ejemplo, el gasto militar de los Estados
Unidos es aproximadamente 3 veces el de China.
Y sí, es verdad que los soldados chinos cobran
mucho menos, pero también lo es que el ejército
chino 1,2 millones de soldados más que el
de los Estados Unidos.
El resultado es que las fuerzas armadas chinas
tienen que pagar muchos salarios, muchos costes
de manutención y muchas más pensiones. Esto
supone una carga gigantesca. Por ejemplo,
se calcula que desde 2008 el aumento del coste
de personal ha devorado más de la mitad de
los aumentos del presupuesto militar chino.
Y por supuesto hoy en día el número de tropas
no es ni mucho menos sinónimo de capacidad
militar. Más bien al contrario.
Lo que cuenta es tener un ejército bien equipado,
bien entrado y con buenas logísticas. Y,
¿Sabéis qué? Ahí Estados Unidos arrasa.
Los números son tan apabullantes que no merece
la pena hacer ninguna comparativa.
(Por si fuera poco el ejército chino tampoco
tiene experiencia de combate y sus entrenamiento
son mucho más pobres. Entre otras cosas porque
las tropas chinas destinan cerca del 20% de
su tiempo a estudiar la ideología comunista
del gobierno chino y asistir a mítines políticos.
Y aunque es verdad que China está haciendo
grandes avances en tecnología militar - hablaremos
de ello aquí en VisualPolitik próximamente
- la distancia con Estados Unidos aún es
sideral.
Para colmo las fronteras de China suponen
un desgaste enorme para sus fuerzas armadas.
¿Por qué? Pues porque no se lleva particularmente
bien con la mayoría de sus vecinos, lo que
le obliga a tener una buena parte de su ejército
disperso por todo el país. En concreto el
ejército chino dedica casi la mitad de sus
fuerzas armadas al control de las fronteras
y la seguridad interna. Un escenario totalmente
diferente al de Estados Unidos cuyo ejercito
está construido casi por completo para extender
su fuerza por todo el mundo.)
Y un último apunte: los vecinos y los aliados.
China se ha convertido en la gran potencia
regional en Asia-Pacífico, pero su peso no
es tan apabullante como podríamos pensar
a simple vista.
Por ejemplo, la armada china es la más poderosa
de la región pero apenas representa en torno
al 30% del tonelaje naval de la zona. Los
esfuerzos de Corea del Sur, Japón, La India,
Taiwán, Australia o Vietnam entre muchos
otros hacen que la competición está más
reñida de lo que parece.
Sobre todo porque la mayoría de estos países
no sólo no son aliados de China sino que
lo son de Estados Unidos. De hecho Estados
Unidos ha ido cerrando alianzas militares
con cada vez más y más países. Sí, en
cuestiones diplomáticas Estados Unidos también
lleva por mucho la delantera.
Amigos, amigas, el futuro no está escrito
y desde luego China se ha convertido en toda
una superpotencia y en un país con una influencia
enorme. Pero lo cierto es que hoy por hoy
los datos sugieren que sigue muy lejos de
Estados Unidos.
Y lo que es aún más importante: todo apunta
a que las diferencias no solo no se están
cerrando sino que incluso puede estar aumentando.
Lo siento por todos aquellos a los que no
os guste la hegemonía norteamericana, pero
por capacidad económica y por capacidad militar
creo que podemos decir sin riesgo a equivocarnos
que hay Estados Unidos para rato.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Cómo crees que se desarrollará la competición
económica y militar entre estas dos potencias?
¿Eres de los que creen que China terminará
sobrepasando a la potencia norteamericana?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
abramos debate.
Y ya sabés no olvides, no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik aunque seas forofo de Xi Jinping.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí. Un saludo y
hasta la próxima.